I've always found it intriguing that
Martin Scorsese,
goodfellas starts it.
Story here,
a car on a deserted road.
Our protagonist,
Henry Hill,
behind wheel is travel companions dozing
off in the background.
No dawn's,
no Tuxedos,
no highbrow melodrama,
just three guys sitting in a car trying
to pass the time,
a scene,
so mundane and so relatable.
Other than these few fleeting seconds
you along with our companions here would
almost forget that this is a gangster
movie.
Of course,
Chris says he's just setting us up for
an early shock reveal
and just like that.
We stopped relating and it's through
relative ease in which Tommy and Jimmy
finished off her begging victim.
That throws us off even more.
Yet we're intrigued.
Social Studies switch the focus to
Henry,
his face lit,
read like he's staring straight into
hell itself.
We didn't invites us to join him and be
our guide in this journey of the bace in
sin and what's become known as one of
the most famous lines in gangster film
history.
As far back as I can remember,
I always wanted to be a gangster
opening credits barely having passed by.
We can already tell that Scorsese,
yes,
they can have 180 degree turn away from
another a gangster movie because instead
of directing his attention upwards on
larger than life characters at the very
top of the mafia hierarchy,
score says he chooses to put the
spotlight on the blue color gangsters
down below in the streets of Queens.
New York didn't find this focal point
and attempted gays.
Have an everyday kid who's only desire
is to become somebody in a world of
nobodies and restore your,
of course is an adaptation of Nicholas
Pileggi book,
White Sky,
which chronicles the life in crime with
the real Henry Hill Square says you
supposedly was so impressed by the
gritty realism and attention to detail
the boot that he decided to treat his
movie adaptation like a stage
documentary,
and we'd attempt to at least preserve
the spirit of adaptive manner.
The most obvious result of which is
conveyed in score says you still have
the voiceover.
One day.
One day,
some of the kids from the neighborhood
carried my mother's groceries all the
way home.
It would perhaps be more fitting to
rebrand Henry's recurring voiceover as a
sort of audio commentary about his own
rise and fall.
It's almost like we're watching the
footage with Henry in every now and
then.
He pauses the film at various important
points you provide us with additional
information.
Henry's wife,
Karen,
is also featured in the voiceover which
adds to the talking heads documentary
like feel of the movie which were says
he stopped just short of actually
showing us Henry watching and
compensating on the food issue himself.
The end result of the strive for realism
is that we get the feeling that what
we're watching is truly authentic slice
of life for you to over romanticizing
with actors behaving redder than acting,
but quite paradoxically.
It's precisely this aspect of the movie
that makes us get drawn into Henry's
experiences even more.
Your watch closely how Henry guides us
through his teams as you rationalizes
away,
why he chose the life right up until the
point that we see him as a full grown
self proclaimed wiseguy.
From that point on,
we hang out with his friends at the bar
you listened to and laugh at Zombie
stories.
We share a shock as the tension builds
and we realized that laughing might not
have been such a great idea after all
to
talk.
We Watch Henry find love.
We even get to see his personal holiday.
Pictures were sucked in.
We rapidly become part of Henry Story to
such an extent that at times we
experience it through his own eyes or as
a sort of extension of himself as he
introduces us to all of his wife's guy
friends in the bamboo bar,
but of course there's really only one
scene that captures this feeling
perfectly.
Copacabana scene really is the apex of
seduction in the film and this three
minute long tracking shot.
We're positioned right behind Henry and
Karen who are going on our first serious
date in the background,
a song.
Then he kissed me by crystal,
starts to play a playful oh,
to seduction itself by taking it back to
her entrance.
Henry shows that he's no longer waiting
around like everyone else,
ironically is a sentence.
You power is then shown by the sense
into the basement door magically opens
for a couple when we entered a lower
corridors of the venue,
athlete colored red as if the two F
major descends into the realms of the
underworld or hell itself everywhere at
a law.
People read.
Henry is Karen walks beside him and
that's a shot.
Moves on and dawns on us at the scene
isn't just all about Henry's moving with
Karen.
No Scorsese has stated himself.
It's also about the lifestyles to
deucing him because it symbolizes
Henry's achieve goals of recognition and
social mobility as he moves into the
club from the back and ends up right at
the center of the stage.
It's a brilliant scene which captures
what scholar folio or Zito as called the
kinetic energy of the film perfectly,
and it's this energy that binds
Scorsese's dry for real,
as tendency towards expressive
stylization that you get her,
which seduce us as much as it does Henry
and Karen.
It's an energy that moves the story
forward and provides them with an almost
unending momentum is the ease with which
things come.
The amount of freedom and control henry
has over his own life that transport him
forward.
I could do anything.
The fact that Henry says this while he
was parking cars as a fitting metaphor
for his sense of mobility and especially
considering the historical context with
the fifties,
with cars being produced en masse and
President Eisenhower proposing to
interstate highway plan in 1955 square
says he then use it as newly increased
freedom of movement as a Motif for both
Henry's as well as the film's own
momentum as can already be observed here
in the opening.
Credits
for Henry car signify a sense of total
control as he sees himself as a driver
of his own life.
This feeling gives henry the impression
that he can do whatever you desires,
like blatantly cheating on his wife and
dealing in cocaine despite of the fact
that Bali told them not to and he's busy
living life in the fast lane,
separated from the rest of us until he
isn't.
Perception does build on and sustained
by the loss of freedom for some and the
loss of life or others are protagonists
are always scared of losing control or
being perceived as someone who founded,
which is white,
Tommy you can handle being put down and
why Jimmy becomes increasingly paranoid
after the Loofah is our rate,
is this combination of fear and greed
that ultimately puts a full stop to the
momentum of Henry's fruit,
a year long ride,
and we come to the conclusion that
despite having had everything actually
had very little sense of control,
has always been in the hands of Bali.
His friends can turn into enemies in
mere seconds,
so he ends his story where he left off
in the state of motionless as a rat.
Moving then drives away from his new
house,
signifying the life,
leaving him behind,
and we of course is aware that we've
been watching as he breaks the fourth
wall right here and the court can mean
anything.
I was broke
or he has consciously been our guide,
our brotherly demon throughout the film,
and we empathize with him because his
desire is to an extent our own henry's
been seduced by life and he doesn't
regret it,
and according to Scorsese,
we are all sinners and we can all
empathize with the characters to do is
my money and power because those
beginning shots of Henry staring out of
his window reflect not only his own
longing for wealth recognition and
control,
but also and perhaps more importantly,
our own voyeuristic gaze into our
protagonist,
sinful in the grief world,
and we just just helped us open up the
blinders to give us a better look
consumer life because he knows all too
well that although we've just been
watching from the sidelines,
there's something very deep inside of us
all that might just be asking you
four more.
Right guys.
That's the end of yet another video
analysis.
As always,
I hope you enjoyed the.
There's just so much substance to
goodfellows that it's just really too
much to talk about.
Uh,
but I hope I managed to capture the main
gist of it,
this video.
Well,
if you do want to know more,
I will upload my additional video
commentary on Goodfellas on our Patrion
page tomorrow.
So check that out.
If you love what we do and helps us out
tremendously,
then I'd like to thank offer Fulvio or
Zito for his article on realism and
formalism,
but trust the main inspiration for this
video.
And of course,
Michael Tucker from lessons of the
screenplay for helping me improve my
audio quality just a little bit.
It's still not perfect,
but I think we're slowly getting there.
All right.
Thank you all for watching and see you
in the next one.